recently we've had a request saying can
computerphile do something on finite
state automata and in considering what
to do about that it did seem to me that
it will be a good idea to look up where
finite state automata sit in the scheme
of things we're done a lot about Turing
machines for example we've covered the
fact that really every single computer
of any sort nowadays is a Turing machine
so what I'd like to do is to refer to a
diagram which shows if you like the
various types of Turing machine the
hierarchy where as you go inside you
make less and less demands on what you
need and if you look at this set of
circles here I can even relate it back
to some of the videos we've done
previously you will remember that when
we were doing the Ackermann function we
eventually decided that is of the
recursive sort which means it will
terminate but it could take an awful
long time if you remember in leading up
to that I said there's a certain sort of
Turing machine outside that which is a
real Sun so which says sometimes the
algorithm you give me will give an
answer and you're happy but sometimes I
will go into a loop and when you say how
can I detect in general that you're in a
loop the answer is you can't and we've
done other videos with my colleague mark
J go all about the halting problem as
it's called and then we went one even
worse we've been out in the outer
perimeter of hyperspace here to say are
there some problems that are so awful
that no algorithm can exist and we did
the busy beaver if you remember which is
for a sort of encoding of a particular
Turing machine it says look there's not
a general algorithm here I'm not trying
to do in fact oriole what I'm asking is
for machines of this sort can you
predict how many zeros I'll print out
and the answer is there isn't an
algorithm that can say how do those busy
beaver previs behave in general if only
the was what you have to do is to run
them all and just exhaustively say
I don't know there isn't an algorithm
just try them what happened after girdle
and cheering and others in the 1930s did
all this as people started say well
these Turing machines you know it's
wonderful they're a pencil and paper
thing but you could imagine building
hardware to do them and of course those
are general-purpose computers as we now
know them but people said is there some
subset of Turing machines where you can
either say it doesn't need more than
this definite amount of RAM guaranteed
that'll be nice to know and those come
out to be in this inner circle of type
one here then people start to say hey
there's this thing called a pushdown
store which the Americans call stack
that's a one ended memory device you
can't dip into it arbitrarily you can
either take something off the top or
push something new on the top so any
addition or so or any reading of your
memory can only be done at the top of
the stack is that a sort of special case
yes it is and we've looked at that with
your towers of Hanoi haven't we yes
chousen panel is a classic example of
something where you just want to get
hold of the whole bunch of disks and
sort them in your hand like Ram you know
just part of that on the store that one
there think about it put them back
together and plump them back on the rod
but you can't do that you can only do it
one ended and for something that you
know you could say I can do that in two
or three moves if only I could take all
the disks off you end up having to do 64
moves and then there's one right in the
middle in this inner circle here that
needs no memory at all in principle and
that's what these finite state automata
are all about you might ask
who discovered all this who filled in
all these gaps because there we are with
Turing who perversely discovers the most
general thing going in the 1930s but
people don't know the simpler story
underneath well the person who
discovered it is still with us I think
it must be in his late eighties now his
name is Noemi Chomsky and I think my
friends say that you ought to fanatic
Tomsky like with her in Locke but I'm
happy to be put right on that he's
genius near genius guy I think he
being at Harvard MIT places like that
ever since he was young he really was
talented he's a linguist Titian if you
study the structure of natural languages
any languages computer languages even I
think I'm ready saying you're a linguist
issue well in the late 1950s he started
saying look to understand natural
languages better I'm going to look at
the most restrictive form of language I
can think of you know really simple
things how about a language whose words
are just strings of letter I so III as a
word five eyes iiiii as a word any
number of eyes is a different word how
simple can that be yes very simple and
then he went on to say things like yeah
what's a bit more complicated than that
because those very simple languages as
we'll find next time don't need any
memory at all they really don't and
what's the one that sits outside he did
more investigations and said ah there is
one where a one ended memory will work
yeah these are the Chomsky type too so
remember Chomsky it goes as it were the
opposite way round type zero is the most
general right the recursively enumerable
x' subset of type 0 is the recursively
numerals that really do terminate a
common type one is the one where it
needs RAM but you can predict how much
RAM so he discovered that sort that's
the type one Turing machines with a
predictable and finite amount of RAM
requirement and he just filled in the
whole picture and in the period really
from about 1959 to the middle 1970s huge
amount of work filling in the middle of
this diagram and that includes things
like computer languages Algol how to
parse them how to compile them it was
all filled in in the middle of this
diagram but all basically referring back
to that work that Chomsky did in 1959
these are the language varieties all one
time and when you get to 25 I'll put it
inside a double circle which is the
convention because that's the finish
date you've put in 25 P and the thing
sort of thinks for a while and
eventually go to preview and print you
out a ticket